it's special like the show is really
special
so to kind of see it turn into what it
turned into it just I don't know let's
get all sad and stuff but I'm just new
to the moment that I read the script
it was so immersive I called my mom and
I said like this is exactly what I want
to play labels are sort of left out of
the story is one of my favorite elements
there's so many characters to relate to
and identities to follow
[Music]
after I watched the pilot I was like yo
like it's brilliant
I was terrified to watch it like I
probably like the rest of our cast had a
mild panic attack but I enjoyed it so
much and I was so proud of what we were
doing great it's really cool to be able
to work with Sam being really specific
with shots and direction
what's amazing about Sam is that he
listens to us and what we went through
and writes true to that so there's a lot
of flavor a lot of creative freedom that
we experience on set from Sam so every
producer to every cast mate every cruel
person you just feel the love shack I
dropped my glasses
I honestly had a lot of fun working with
Alexa and Maud and everybody a part of
this I've created a new family it just
has been an absolute dream we big
carnival chili big popcorn even the best
time well it felt like we'd known each
other for like ten years
not in they kind of stayed with the
process it made all of the traumatic
work that we had to do better it felt
really good
[Applause]
we're sure we're sure come on our last
day of shooting was such a weird bundle
of emotions everybody was so happy and
excited to be there but then it was also
like everything's coming to an end like
it's our last day I'm like no no like
I'm good like we'll see each other it's
fine like I'm not gonna get emotional
[Music]
[Applause]
it's just become very special to me not
only in like a work sense but in a
personal sense you know
[Music]
a lot of love is in this project I think
it's really exciting to like see where
it can go
[Music]
you